a lake near the arctic circle is covered
by a two meter thick sheet of ice during
the cold winter months
when spring arrives the warm air
gradually melts the ice causing its
thickness to decrease at a constant rate
it's going to decrease at a constant
rate
after three weeks the sheet is only 1.25
meters thick after three weeks the sheet
is only 1.25
meters thick let s of t denote the ice
sheet's thickness s measured in meters
as a function of time measured in weeks
write the functions formula
all right so we got we have some
interesting things here they've given us
some values for this function we know
when time is equal to zero
we know that s of zero when time equals
zero
that's when the sheet is two meters
thick so the s of zero is equal to two
and they also tell us that after three
weeks the sheet is only 1.25 meters
thick and when we say when we have the
function s of t s is measured in meters
time is measured in weeks so after zero
weeks we're two meters thick and then
they tell us after three weeks so s of
three
after three weeks we're 1.25
1.25
meters thick or another way to think
about it
another way to think about it i could
write
t here in weeks and s in meters and when
time is 0 we're two meters thick
and when time is one point sorry when
time is three weeks
when time is three weeks we are 1.25
meters thick
so when our change in time
our change in time is equal to positive
three we increased our time by three
what's our change what's our change in
thickness our change in thickness
the triangle here that's the greek
letter delta the shorthand for change in
well this was negative
0.75
negative 0.75
so what was the rate of change over this
time and they tell us that the rate of
change is a as a constant rate so
whatever it is between these two periods
of time between zero weeks and three
weeks it would be that same rate it
would be that same rate between any two
periods of time between zero week and
one week or one week in two weeks or one
and a half weeks and 1.6 weeks so what
is the rate of change what is the rate
of change of
thickness
relative to time
well it's going to be change in
thickness
over change in time how much does our
thickness change per time
well we saw right over here our
thickness went down
set
0.75 meters
0.75 meters in three weeks
in three
in three weeks
or we could say that this right over
here is equal to
let's see 75 divided by 3 is 25 so 0.75
divided by 3 is 0.25 and we have the
negative out there negative 0.25
meters
per
per week
so how can we take the information we
have and express this as a function it's
going to be a linear function because we
see that we are changing
at a constant rate
let's think about it a little bit linear
functions one way we could write it is
in
so we could write it if we were dealing
with x and y you might recognize y is
equal to mx plus b often write written
as slope intercept form this is when
you're dealing with x x is the i guess
you could say the independent variable y
is the dependent variable and b would be
where you start what happens when x
equals 0
and m is your rate of change it's your
slope
so in this case we're going to have
we're not we don't have y and x we're
going to have s and t
we have s as a function of time and it's
going to be equal to the rate of change
times time
plus where we started
plus b
now what is b going to be
what is b going to be
well one way to think about it is well
what's a what's s of 0 going to be s of
0 s of 0
is going to be m times 0 plus b s of 0
is going to be b but we already know
that this ice sheet it starts off at 2
meters thick so s of 0 is equal to b is
equal to 2 so b is equal to 2
and what is m well we've already said
that's our rate of change that is our
slope that is how much our our depth how
much our thickness changes with respect
to time and we already figured out that
that's negative
0.25
so m
is
negative 0.25
you could say that m is the slope
between this point between the point 0
comma 2 and the point 3 comma 1.25 if we
were plotting these points on a ts
coordinate plane
so now we can write what the function is
going to be maybe i'll do this in a new
color just for fun
s of t
thickness as a function of time is going
to be equal to m
negative 0.25
times time
plus
plus 2. or if you want you could write
it like this 2 minus 0.25
t i actually like this form a little bit
better it kind of in my brain it kind of
describes what's happening a little bit
more when time is equal to 0 you're
starting it you're starting at 2 meters
thick and then every week that goes by
as t increases by one you're going to
lose a quarter of a meter you're going
to lose lose you have a negative value
right over here you're going to lose
0.25
meters and if you really want to kind of
get this even deeper i encourage you to
graph it it'll become even clearer
what's going on here that this right
over here is this right over here this
is the slope of of the of the the the
line that represents the solution set to
this equation and this 2 this would be
your vertical intercept in this case
would be your s-intercept as opposed to
your y-intercept when y is the vertical
axis